i had learned how to scale product to
the low thousands and i now wanted to
learn how to scale product to the
millions
[Music]
sean thank you so much for being here on
20 minute leaders
thanks for having me michael we've known
each other for
for many years starting uh from the mitx
elevator
and from the days of any meal which you
so graciously advised
and we've been into touch since and i
recently visited you in seattle
give me the round down you've had a
pretty fascinating experience
all the way from a startup to amazon to
to what you're doing now
and more in the accelera accelerator
investment space talk to me about a bit
about your journey
yeah sure so i really identified in grad
school that i wanted to go
and build a startup but i didn't have a
great idea
so unfortunately i went back into
what i was doing beforehand which was
management consulting
and that was great about nine months
into that
something fell into my lap that was
super unfortunate
which was a family member had passed
away
and they were running a pet boarding
facility a doggie daycare
and i went to go help my family manage
that business
and in the process of doing that i
realized
there was no good software to manage
what was
a very antiquated uh
software uh for the entire industry
and the more i dove into it and the more
i saw the pain points
that my family members and our
staff uh had while using the product
just me lit a fire under my butt to say
i have to fix this
and so i spent the first six
months just understanding the problem
and talking to as many people about the
problem as i could
i went to trade shows i went to other
pet boarding facilities i talked to
facility owners
how big is this problem ped boarding
so in the u.s there's over 10 000 pet
boarding facilities
um according to ibis and very other
various other
uh market research companies but there's
many more
grooming uh businesses and training
companies
dog training and and things like that so
what was interesting about this space
was that it actually flew under the
radar
from vcs because even though there's
10 000 pet boarding facilities the
overall pam for this market
was literally like just a few billion
dollars
at the most and that's the revenue
generated from pet boarding facilities
not the revenue generated from software
for these facilities
so it was a much smaller market right so
it really flew under the radar
and it wasn't given the attention it
deserved
because the average facility owner just
was not technologically
savvy and they had relied on solutions
that had been around for 20 years most
notably pen and paper
or excel
so continuing this journey of mine
i ultimately identified some co-founders
that had a similar passion as i did
really more of an obsession
in fixing this problem and so i moved
out to boulder colorado
um where my co-founders were based and
we
founded a company called ginger right
and how was that how was that decision
to move to to move to boulder colorado
instead of you know coming to palo alto
or
sf or something of that sort yeah so
i had been going to boulder my entire
life um
i knew this was where techstars was born
there was a strong
uh venture presence maybe not strong but
there was definitely like an
angel presence there that was very
entrepreneurial
uh focused and it was just a great
startup ecosystem so i was thrilled to
be there
not to mention all the great outdoor
activities that we're here as well
that's cool so it fit really well
um long story short without diving into
all the details because we only have
15 minutes or so the company
was acquired um and i moved out to
amazon so i had learned how to scale
product to uh the low thousands
and i now wanted to learn how to scale
product to the millions
and so i made that leap into amazon
um working for the home innovation team
yeah and during my time on the in the
home innovation team i noticed there was
a ton of brilliant product managers and
brilliant engineers
who had startup ideas but they never
wanted to take the leap of faith
and build that startup full-time and so
here i was coming off of an acquisition
and
i was really focused on paying it
forward i got involved with techstars
as a mentor to support other founders
uh through the techstar seattle program
as well as the techstars alexa
accelerator
and i just wanted to continue paying it
forward and so what we did was while at
amazon we put together
a group of people from microsoft google
amazon all the big tech companies here
in the seattle area
and we said what would you need to
cut the cord and pursue your startup
idea full time
and it really came down to three things
one they wanted some level of mentorship
two they wanted some programming and
three they wanted some resources
which can mean a variety of things but
if you boil that down
um it really comes down to community
while you're
stuck away in your cubicle somewhere um
working super hard on
solving a problem for a big tech company
it's hard to
know where the resources are to help you
with your startup
and that's where we came in we provided
the community support
so when you did weave you had that
support network
interesting so so really i mean talk to
me a little bit about this experience
within amazon and because it's not very
common where you get to both
to experience the three fields both
being
a startup you know an entrepreneur and
then a mentor for startups but also
working
uh diligently within a company such as
amazon which is obviously
um which you know one of the big big
companies that also has a lot of
uh you know a lot of culture issues
sometimes or different
ways it deals with culture and there's a
lot of things in that realm right
yeah absolutely i will say um you know
people do have mixed feelings on amazon
and amazon's culture
i personally loved it the leadership
principles
what was it like yeah yeah so
it was very entrepreneurial in my mind i
was on
a team that had the word innovation in
it so we were literally coming up with
new products
amazing for millions of people
and we really worked hard to
identify and think about the customer
and the customer's need
and what an amazing customer experience
would look like and how to delight the
customer
and so everything i've done ford has
really
had that principle in mind uh
in everything i do but there's also a
lot of
other really great leadership principles
that have carried through that i think
are important for any
startup founder and it's the ability to
dive deep it's the ability to invent and
simplify
um it's the ability to disagree and
commit with the co-founder
so you know everyone from time to time
can disagree with the co-founder right
but you have to be able to move on past
that um
and sometimes that takes time and amazon
was a
an incredible training ground to do that
yeah and you know getting to the getting
to do that with
products that are then going to be faced
facing you know millions of potential
customers
is something that's pretty pretty
exciting so where are you now tell me
about your latest venture
and which is actually helping you know
dozens of entrepreneurs go their own
path
absolutely so after doing these monthly
meet up like events here in the seattle
area for venture out
what we realized was um
people more and more people wanted to do
this they wanted to participate they
wanted to be part of the community
this was very different than a meetup
group where you just network get a
business card maybe get a connection
our number one goal was to build
community and to be able to pay it
forward and give back to
to that community and really support the
seattle startup ecosystem
and so after doing this for two years
and having our member base grow from
20 around a table to a couple hundred we
thought there was a full-time
opportunity to support
founders who wanted to leave big tech
that were moonlighting in their day job
provide them with support and enable
them to ultimately cut the core of their
day job and pursue that startup
full-time
so this past january we launched a
10-week program that had four key goals
to it
the first goal was during the course of
the program to acquire beta users
two paying customers three
get a line of sight to a quarter million
dollars or more in funding
and four for some it might have meant to
go on to
a y combinator like uh accelerator
program
now if you could not accomplish any of
those four in the ten weeks we hope the
fifth goal happened
which was we're able to kill your idea
in program so you go back to your day
job like nothing happened
but now you know the entire process but
how did that happen because
how so are they're not supposed to cut
the cord
while they're in their 10-week right
that's right
so they're maintaining their full-time
day job this is what you might think
of as like a part-time accelerator so it
was night and weekend
so they keep their day job so we never
want to compete with the yc or
techstars we think those are amazing
programs and i still support some of
those programs here in seattle and i
love the people behind them
but we're trying to provide something
that's slightly differentiated
it's differentiated in two ways one it's
focusing on
employees in big tech who want to
moonlight
and two this is night and weekend so you
keep your day job
um until you have the signal from the
market that
you can like have you have customers you
have users
and they want what you're what you're
offering now that makes a lot of sense
john because
you know one of the things that
definitely vcs and and the angel groups
a lot of them are looking for is
full-time commitment obviously
and having you skin in the game and
while somebody is
still moonlighting for a company then
it's very unattractive
for for another investor to come in but
here you're saying
well wait let's let's break down the
picture and understand that there are
these incredible incredible people
who have incredible jobs in the big
companies
but they also have a value proposition
and this idea that
if we just let them test it out and give
them the resources to get the product to
get some signal from the market
then they'll feel comfortable making
this transition and you're reducing the
barrier to entry for a lot of these
entrepreneurs right
yeah absolutely and i'll just add to
that that many of the engineers and
product managers that we work with
have already shown that they're highly
qualified and highly skilled in what
they do because they've been hired by
google apple microsoft facebook etc
so these are individuals who have
de-risked their profile to extent where
if they do
take that risk to go build their startup
and for whatever reason it doesn't work
out the way it's supposed to they could
go back tomorrow and get a job at any of
these big tech companies
because they're so good at what they do
so
it's not as a risky proposition for some
of them
to come in for 10 weeks validate what
they're working on
and then if the signal is there to cut
the cord and pursue it full-time
definitely and then so what what's your
stake in this because you must be
going into some sort of partnership with
these with these entrepreneurs right
yeah so we really my co-founder ken and
i
we really view ourselves as co-founders
to
all of the people in the program because
oftentimes these are not teams these are
teams of one
who just have a brilliant idea and are
coding
on something and they need someone to
like go into the weeds with them and
soundboard so
the way our model works is we take four
percent equity for participation in the
program
but it goes on well past our support
goes on well past that
okay that makes a lot of sense now and
but these are not necessarily even
incorporated yet right so
it's it i mean the really the four
percent materializes when and if
this becomes on adventure later on yeah
absolutely and we've baked into our
model that a majority
the majority of these founders or
startups
will fail but our number one goal with
venture out is building community
and so we know that equipping them with
the tools today
even if this doesn't work out in the
future they're gonna come back around
and either a
support other founders or come to us for
support to work with us
on their next one definitely no you you
graciously invited me to one of your
events
back a few months ago and i remember
that as people were speaking and there
were a few teams that came and they and
they spoke and
it was just so clear how much value they
got out of working with you guys and
with the program that it was to me on
the sidelines was very very evident
that that you're providing them with so
much value give me a little bit of
insight into
what you've learned so far from working
with these entrepreneurs and these
founders so there was one cohort that's
that was in january right and how many
people were there
yeah so we had eight startups in that
first cohort
um we did a a soft launch where
we reached out primarily to the 50 plus
mentors that are part of venture out to
work with these founders
yeah and we relied on our network to
provide us with inbound for applicants
for this first program
and so out of those eight startups we
we had a couple that decided to hang it
up um and we view that as a success by
the way because they're now
not spending the next year their life
building something and that won't work
no no definitely yeah and we have other
startups
that are now raising money they raising
capital they
are acquiring customers one is in the
healthcare space called gene mod
it's just very good timing for them with
what they're doing
to support those in healthcare and
that's been awesome to see
and so i think some of the key learnings
and these are things that you and i
might have
realized from the start but while you're
in a big tech company you might not
think about as much this is almost like
a second full-time job
um it's at least another 15 hours a week
a minimum of work you have to put into
this
and if you have kids family a demanding
job
it's challenging to do both and it's
very time demanding
so that's something we try to get across
very early on
and second we now use this as a way to
weed out potential applicants is the
number of customer discovery
interviews that they have conducted so
if a founder comes in and applies for
the program
and they've done under 50 customer
discovery interviews
we ask them to do another three within
the next 48 hours
and come back to us with their findings
because at this super early stage
for me it really comes down to a couple
basic things
one do you have some level of domain
expertise
in the space do you have some obsession
over the problem set
and do you have the motivation to go
get stuff done that gsd factor right
because at this early stage there's so
many unknown variables
but if you have those three things we
can work with you and one of the ways we
now weed that out is by knowing how many
customer discovery interviews they've
done
and how quickly they can do more
interesting is that something that's
also common to other
accelerators this testing by saying how
many
customer customer discovery interviews
you've done
um i don't know specifically i will say
having worked with other accelerators
that they probably vet this out
indirectly
by understanding their hustle factor
a little bit and their scrappiness i
also love founders that are super
scrappy
and at my time at the alexa accelerator
powered by techstars
um we talked to candidates there and
asked them to go back
and interview a couple candidates and
the ones who did that
got a spot in the program and so every
week when
we come to the board and do our metrics
we say
okay what have you done this week and
how many more people have you talked to
and for us that's a key factor in
understanding the success of the founder
because it's something tangible that
they can build momentum off
of and momentum is a key part of making
progress
and in a program like this 100 sean
give me in two words where is this
headed
so how do you envision this this program
running i don't know
three years from now yeah so we want to
help as many founders as possible
that have big tech work experience
so right now we're doubling down in
seattle because there's
such a strong ecosystem here and our
target demographic
is growing by the day but we see a world
wherever there's a big tech presence
outside of the bay in new york city
where we can go to these other cities
and support
more people who want to moonlight and
pursue a startup
incredible before we before we finish a
i'm going to put you on the spot one
time
and i want you to tell me sean three
words that you
think would best describe yourself or
that
can your co-founder or any of the eight
portfolio companies
would describe sean as gosh great
question um
i think the first would say uh my
co-founder ken would say is that i'm
meticulous in the details maybe uh too
much
uh so uh so that's one
two i think he would say that i'm a
little bit more of a happy-go-lucky kind
of guy
in that i try not to take life too
seriously uh
because we're just uh
we never know how long we're here for so
we might as well enjoy the ride
and then three um really
uh carry about family and friends and
and those around me and making sure that
um everyone's doing okay and i think i
get that from my mom but
uh that would be the last one i love it
sean thank you so much this was so great
thanks michael i really enjoyed chatting
with you love what you're doing here
talk to you soon
thank you